this is the standard form okay now some
books call it the general form and they
call the standard form the vertex form
so you might want to take a look at your
textbook and see if you need to refer to
my video on the vertex form of a
quadratic but for purposes here we're
just gonna call this the standard form
this is just a foiled form or the
descending form or you can see it's
going in descending order with the
degrees of each term but let's take a
look at how to actually graph a parabola
when it's in this this form well what
you want to do is you want to find the
vertex and to find the vertex we're
going to start off by finding the x
coordinate of the vertex and the way we
do that is by using this formula x
equals negative B over 2a so you can see
the coefficients okay those are your
variables a B and C so we're going to do
negative B over 2a to find our
x-coordinate of our vertex so you can
see here this is going to be the B value
so negative 2 times 2 times 1 you see
there's a 1 in front of the x squared
that's one so that's going to come out
to negative one so what that means is
that's the x coordinate of the vertex
it's also the equation of the axis of
symmetry
so over here at negative one that's our
axis of symmetry right there okay x
equals negative 1 if we put negative 1
back into our equation we can solve for
the y coordinate of the vertex so let's
do that we've got y equals negative 1
squared plus 2 times negative 1 plus 1
so if we simplify this we get 1 minus 2
plus 1 which equals 0 okay so what that
tells us is that our vertex is at
negative 1 comma 0 so that's gonna be
right there okay now how do we get some
additional points on our graph well if
you focus in on this first part of the
equation
okay the y equals ax squared part this
is what we call our parent function it
gives us the shape of the graph whether
it's wide or whether it's new
whether it's opening up if he is
positive or opening down if a is
negative so we're gonna zero in on this
part of the equation and that's y equals
x squared in our example here and what
we're gonna do is we're gonna make a
table so let's make a table here pick
some easy values okay so all I do is I
put 0 in 0 squared is 0 1 squared is 1
which is 1 and 2 squared is 4 ok so now
what we're gonna do is we're going to
plot those points but not from the
origin like we normally do we're going
to plot those from the vertex ok so 1 1
I'm going to go right one up one left 1
up 1 because it's symmetric about this
axis of symmetry right 2 up 4 so 1 2 1 2
3 4 okay right there and I'm gonna go
left 2 up 4 ok there we go let's draw
our parabola